well there's another super tall building
on earth the Japanese just announced
this week the completion of the Tokyo
Skytree it's a broadcast tower so it's
not populated all the way up but it's a
two thousand eighty feet high which
makes it not the tallest building in the
world that's still the Burj Khalifa in
Dubai 2,700 feet almost half a mile and
I kind of love these buildings I'm not
always sure why we build them you know
obviously they have functions like
broadcasting digital TV or being a place
for a hotel in an office building or
being a somewhat phallic display of a
country's architectural and financial
prowess I suppose but I think there's
something more going on the skyscrapers
I really I really quite love them and
some of that I think is because they
give us access to a different world I'll
tell you what I mean when I live in
Tokyo when I was in college they just
completed the tokyo city hall it's kind
of this double barreled postmodern thing
and the observation deck I know talking
about observation decks on a show called
observation deck is a little on the nose
sorry I'll get past it going up to the
observation deck cost some money I was a
poor student didn't have it so I used to
go up in the sky scraper next door so i
could see Tokyo so I could be in a place
where I could get an angle on a city
that didn't exist anywhere else a built
space that I could see these other built
spaces I did the same thing in any other
city i would go to Chicago LA if I could
in New York especially New York I ate it
windows on the world a couple of times
the restaurant that used to be at the
top of the world trade center and once
when I was 18 for my birthday and then
again when I was there when i was in
dolton I'd mistimed that dinner I I
scheduled it on a day that turned out to
be overcast so there was no view of the
city in fact the towers were the only
things you could see sticking up above
the cloud layer and there was something
special about being in in a built bubble
where the only structure were the only
city really was the place that we were
sitting and eating of course those
aren't there anymore that powers are
gone and you can actually go to that
place and look up and see a point in
space that used to be enclosed but isn't
in fact that's a point in space and a
point in time right because it used to
be there and isn't there anymore or
something different now and that got me
thinking
when I was reading about that Tokyo
Tower about an article I read a couple
years ago talking about gravitational
time dilation a relativistic effect
gravity slows time down the closer you
are to the ground the slower time moves
so for every meter that you move up a
second is 1.1 times 10 to the minus 16th
shorter that's infinitesimal but if you
start to get up into these skyscrapers
it's well slightly less infinitesimal
the top of the Burj Khalifa it's nine
point one times ten to the minus 14 the
second is that much shorter the top of
that Tokyo Skytree it's five point two
times ten to the minus 14 these are
super small numbers I mean it would take
millions of years at the top one of
these buildings for your watch to gain a
second on watch those on the ground but
there's still something kind of magical
about being in a spacetime bubble at the
top of a building in a place that only
exists in a moment in space and time it
is unearthly